yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and i'm here with
another quick tutorial uh this tutorial
is more or less about a ton of questions
i've been getting so yes this is a
request video uh but there are no
channel links in the description because
this was so highly requested i've gotten
a lot of questions about how i got
safari three uh never even never even
minding the home page how i got safari 3
to have those arrow borders now i'm
running windows vista home premium
64-bit
and it does have those uh those windows
outsides it has the um the little
transparency going on the outside and
the transparent toolbar
and um
instead of having a little mac os 10 the
tiny little dots and i i do remember
watching a video about how to do it but
every time someone asked i couldn't
really recall it so now that i've found
the way and i've actually um
given a few people the answer i'll be
able to show you guys now how to do it
so here's the uh here's what it'll look
like first of all we're going to go into
our start menu and type in safari uh so
that we can actually uh go into safari's
properties right click on it or you
could do this to the icon on your
desktop it works the same way and go to
properties
and actually in properties if we just go
under compatibility
which is the third tab from the left or
the right you'll see uh disable visual
themes now normally that will be
unchecked and it'll look like this so
i'll apply hit okay open safari and you
see here it has those tiny little mac os
10 buttons you don't get that arrow
theme so now let me exit this out and
right click on safari go to properties
compatibility
and what we're going to do is disable
visual themes because the visual themes
that apple applies to uh safari is
actually that that toolbar thing because
um basically windows wants to apply that
arrow toolbar to every application
unless it has a different sort of theme
like a game or something so yeah we just
hit apply we hit okay
and every time you open up safari from
now on it'll look a little more like
firefox or whatever you want it to look
like and it has that aero theme so i
hope this i hope this tutorial is
helpful to you guys i hope you uh you
enjoy that new aero theme kind of
looking a little like sapphire for beta
but not sacrificing uh any of the
features you liked in safari 3. so
thanks for watching this one guys and i
hope it was helpful and uh stay tuned i
got two or three more hardware videos
and unboxing i got a lot of stuff a lot
of ideas also for more tutorials for you
guys so if you like what you see here
subscribe and trust me you'll be entered
into all my giveaways that's a new thing
and that's basically it so thanks for
watching peace